and I think it's between SGA and Luca I
can't take L I can't not take Luca this
is for best point best point guard or
best leag guard best leag guard he's a
point guard I year is a point guard he's
a league guard he's a high usage rate
and controls the flow of you he listen I
I I mean what is the point guard or
Luka I'm going have to take him wow
luuka is a fa player but this kid listen
he plays the right way gets his
teammates involved and when he puts his
head down goes to the basket no one sh
we're talking about right now I'm right
now right now no similar yeah I'm taking
him right now he's he's definitely he's
definitely emerg as one of my favorite
players to watch CU I like I like I like
stories like this guys that come out of
nowhere and then they're forced to be
reckoned with he's a hell of a player
right now